california's green energy dream turning
into a nightmare for millions and biden
sees it as a blueprint for the rest of
the country california urged residents
yet again to conserve energy during peak
hours as the state faces the biggest
blackout risk of the year amid a brutal
heat wave the state's liberal governor
gavin newsom looking pretty cozy in a
fleece jacket sitting in seemingly
air-conditioned room while begging his
residents to make the sacrifice
everyone has to do their part to help
step up for just a few more days when
the early morning hours particularly
tomorrow and the next day or so pre-cool
your home run your air conditioning
earlier in the day when more power is
available close your windows and blinds
to keep your home cool as well
and today and tomorrow afternoon after 4
p.m in particular 4 p.m please turn your
thermostat up to 78 degrees or higher
and this is the state that biden
administration says is the leader in
energy policies
i love the fact that california is
unabashedly bold about about energy
policy the leader leading indicator for
the rest of the country california's
boldness
has i think shaped our
willingness in the federal government to
move further and faster
okay i'm going to start uh with you
harold um that energy secretary is so
proud of california and a little bad
timing because within a few hours you
know the governor's up there in his
fleece jacket because he cooled his
house telling everybody to turn up their
thermostats
so i'm i'm i'm confounded a little bit
by some of my party uh there's there's
nothing wrong and i think the country
and and what we've seen in the world in
the last several months has shown us
that we've got to wean ourselves off of
fossil fuels but we can't do it all at
once it took 40 years from us to go from
coal to natural gas
and it's going to take uh hopefully it
takes a shorter period of time for us to
graduate
to
having multiple sources of energy now
you know i i don't know where governor
news was with the fleece jack and it
probably was not not the greatest look
uh and everyone was when everyone was
hot out there but i like big big bold
ideas like like the former governor of
michigan and energy secretary you think
about what we celebrate today the
release of iphone 14 steve jobs was as
big an entrepreneur as bigger thinker as
big a darren biggest dreamer and frankly
was criticized often you could you
identified a woman and you omt a few
days ago madame cj walker was the first
female self-made millionaire she was
criticized in her lifetime for having
big dreams she was also african-american
i think about elon musk i think about
president trump and operation warp speed
i think about biden with the moonshot in
cancer and i even think about kennedy
and putting us on the moon i'd rather be
around big-minded people with big dreams
who are big dares and then then i would
little-minded short-sighted people when
we face big big challenges now democrats
we need an all-of-the-above energy
strategy harold turning down the
thermostat isn't a big idea
well then
let me go let me go to you greg i mean
the truth is that
that what you have to have is you have
to have a transition and you know the
big idea is great except you don't want
to punish people along the way i would
agree so go ahead
okay there is california is literally in
a bad state right but how did it happen
that's the thing and i have to look at
this because
my opinions have been shifting
it's not climate change that has done
this it's the climate change activist
that poisoned the dialogue with hysteria
for 30 40 maybe 50 years i mean imagine
if instead of crying wolf they were
talking wolf right it might actually if
you remove the constant hyperbole
somebody like me would have actually
been on your side but i became so
cynical and distrustful and alienated by
these people that were constantly
fear-mongering i didn't trust them at
all and then i saw that the
fear-mongering was becoming like a cash
cow you could see it in the media there
were all these specials about it
everybody's talking about it if you want
to get a good magazine
portrait or interview on you talk about
the environment it's suddenly everybody
was talking about climate because it was
good for their pocketbook and that made
me think it was even more suspicious so
all of this has had terrible
consequences one it falsely smeared uh
clean alternatives like nuclear power
it's taken decades for nuclear power to
climb back on its feet and it all was
due to hyperbole uh and then you have
people like me who could not take the
shrieking psycho brats you know like
greta thundberg screaming at me you know
she probably did more to undermine the
green movement than monsanto because you
can't take it seriously when you have a
woman or a girl going how dare you
how dare you well how dare you yeah
crazy lady dana when california passed a
law saying that you couldn't buy any gas
powered cars after 2035
virginia says hey we're tied into this
ridiculous
legislation and they're trying to wean
their way out of that um how do you
think that that happened and like where
do they go well it's really interesting
several state legislatures decided to do
what california did and this is part of
the way that the democrats were figuring
out a way to get a federal law basically
that they couldn't pass in the congress
so they're like well if california does
it and then if we hitch our wagons to
them and we make it mandatory that you
have to stay with them then we'll be on
the hook for it as well so that it was
just clever but it also is going to uh
it's going to come back to bite them how
does california think it's going to go
when electric cars go from 15 today to
100 percent and they're not building any
new electricity that this doesn't build
any more energy capacity
in addition they just passed 300 billion
dollars of aid to green energy companies
in the inflation reduction act and then
they put a very effective democratic
operative in charge of putting giving
out that money john podesta oh john
podesta this will be solyndra
3.0
and
unlike the school money that wasn't
spent believe me 300 billion is going to
get spent and i'm all for a big idea i
don't know if you're going to get one
from here in the meantime also i point
out in europe they're about to have a
very dark and cold winter because
they've had terrible policies that have
led them to this moment we're going to
have a geopolitical crisis on our hands
we're probably going to have to figure
out a way to go out there and do even
more to help them but our liquid natural
gas it's it's great but we have not kept
up with the infrastructure and europe is
going to need it wouldn't you rather buy
liquid natural gas from the united
states and have to rely on putin
obviously this is a huge huge problem
and california is a warning for all of
the rest of us you know jesse just as
dana said i mean california has also
shuttered a whole bunch of gas-powered
plants so they're making it even worse
for themselves and the electric grid
that's right on the edge right now
doesn't even have the number of electric
cars that's going to be on there so yeah
it's a fragile grid pretend california
is my body
no i need
a well balanced
to fuel my body i need greens i need
fruits i need protein i need grains
okay
you don't all of a sudden just give your
body greens
you know as much as we want to eat
cheese and bread you don't just give
your body cheese you need a
well-balanced
energy diet just like you do this one
it's a fad 100 green is a fad it can't
happen and that's why they're saying
we're going to get rid of natural gas
and coal and nukes and then they keep
pushing back the deadline because it
doesn't make any sense you know what
they're doing in la and some of the
poorer neighborhoods to power their
homes they're burning kerosene
they're burning diesel because that's
the only thing they can do to keep their
lights on there's a solar power plant in
southern california
is 305
000 square miles
and it only powers
140 000 homes the natural gas plant pg e
powers 16 million homes meanwhile it's
incinerating birds birds see bugs on the
panels they fly right into the solar
panels and they burst into flames it's
also killing the tortoise population
i thought liberals love tortoises and
they built this other one on an indian
burial ground it's not a great idea
the brady bunch said that was red stuff
don't do anything on idiot burial
grounds never never hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else